after a very long silence Trump has
finally tweeted about stormy Daniels did
you know that yes
yeah good noises by the way no friend he
had people been waiting is he gonna say
anything he finally did President Trump
tweeted that the sketch of the man
stormy Daniels accused of threatening
her life is fake that's what he said
yeah Trump said it looks nothing like me
that was it's my birthday for guys
that's so wrong no that's just wrong bye
2/6 joking it's like once again
President Trump has referred to
mar-a-lago as the southern White House
yeah yeah of course when Trump refers to
the actual White House he refers to it
as the Western Kremlin this is crazy
it's come out that the CIA director Mike
Pompeo recently had a secret meeting
with Kim jong-un yes yeah when asked how
it all came about
Pompeyo said I just swiped right that's
all I did
Republicans and Congress are urging the
FBI to launch an investigation into
Hillary Clinton yeah man
Hillary Clinton what did she do over two
years ago now I'm just curious in 1968
yeah yeah she didn't return a library
book
hey this exciting SpaceX is planning to
build a Mars rocket right here in Los
Angeles
yeah The Voyage Samaras will take nine
months but eight of those months will be
spent just getting out of La it's a lot
of people in the crowd like he's right
you know
yeah in Florida an 87 year old man has
donated 100 gallons of blood throughout
his lifetime the weird thing is only
half of it is his
just people are wondering what it means
chillin
hey this is inspiring scientists have
developed a robot that can assemble a
chair from Ikea almost as fast as a
human yeah sadly in the process of
assembling it the robot has a huge fight
with his wife that's the big problem
yeah you lost a little ring yeah have
you ever gotten through that process
without just losing it
no no it's incredibly frustrating yeah
yeah yeah in a while it was most of my
kids furniture it was all kids furnish
that we'd have to build and then like
they'd want it right away so it was
usually yelling at the kids which right
it's much easier because my wife is
scary yes she is
all right Apple
I'm backing you up I know I know my
wife's scary too yeah give me a
gluten-free bun this morning I'll tell
you more about that later that was my
big gift here's your gluten-free muffin
Bing we'll cut that out don't worry I
don't want it what is that I mean yeah
that's what I got for breakfast this
morning for my birthday my kids and my
wife gave me a gluten-free muffin with a
candle jammed in it we're gonna have to
cut this out no just leave it in all
right
I love them but come on I know we want
you to live a long joyless life day I
hate the candle too
you